We humans understand borders and border walls.
Animals, however, do not.
Animals stand to possibly be the most affected
by the proposal to build a wall along the
U.S.-Mexico border.
There are dozens of species that have moved
freely across that border for centuries.
They do so because the natural environment
around the U.S. and Mexico border isn’t
all that different.
The only thing that differentiates those two
pieces of land, is that humans have divided
it with an invisible line.
So, not understanding our social and political
structures, animals cross unknowingly back
and forth over the line in search of food
or water or mates, or whatever.
But when former president George W. Bush passed
the Secure Fence Act in 2006, 670 miles of
walls and fences were actually built.
And this gave scientists a glimpse into what
happens when animals are confronted with human
walls.
They discovered that animals become confused
when they approached the wall, unsure about
what to do next.
Researchers documented mountain lions, ocelots
and deer as having their natural movements
disrupted.
Some bison have even tried to climb over the
barbed wire fence to get to water supplies.
This phenomenon is not unique to the United
States..
Europe is witnessing an intense proliferation
of border walls due to the ongoing refugee
crisis there, and animals are dying as a consequence.
Some individual animals are getting physically
caught in the fences.
But then there are entire species, like the
brown bear and eurasian lynx, that are having
their ranges simply cut off from them.
Back in the U.S., scientists are now most
concerned with what an even longer wall might
do to species whose populations are dwindling.
Cutting off populations on either side of
the border could mean further harming already
threatened species.
There are about 111 endangered or at-risk
of being endangered species along the border,
including the last known jaguar left in all
of the United States.
The only chance at rebuilding that population
would be if the jaguars that live in Mexico’s
Sierra Madre Occidental forests would find
their way up to the U.S. and mate with that
last remaining jaguar.
A wall would make that nearly impossible.
Same goes for the gray wolf.
Section 7 of the Endangered Species Act stipulates
that any construction project that involves
the federal government must be reviewed by
the U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service for any
endangered populations who might be impacted
by the construction.
So far, the federal government has not filed
such a review for the newly proposed wall.
Humans have many options when crossing borders.
Sure, a wall makes things more difficult,
but people can find ways over, under, and
around tall structures.
It takes animals a lot longer to adapt to
major changes in their environment like these,
and for some species, it might take them long
enough so that they become extinct.
For more Seeker videos, make sure you subscribe
and thanks for watching!